let's say you're studying some type of a
little hill or rock formation right over
here and you're able to figure out the
dimensions you know that from this point
to this point along the bay straight
along level ground is 60 meters you know
the steeper side steeper i guess surface
or edge of this cliff or whatever you
want to call it is 20 meters and then
the longer side here i guess the less
deep side is 50 meters long so you're
able to measure that but now what you
want to do is use your knowledge of
trigonometry
given this information to figure out how
steep is the side what is the actual
inclination relative to level ground or
another way of thinking about it
what is this angle theta right over
there
i encourage you to pause the video and
think about it on your own
well it might be ringing a bell well you
know
you know three sides of a triangle and
then we want to figure out an angle and
so the thing that jumps out in my head
is well maybe the law of cosines could
be useful let me just write out the law
let me just write out the law of cosines
before we try to apply it to this
triangle right over here so the law of
cosines tells us that c squared is equal
to a squared plus b squared minus 2 a b
times the cosine of
theta
and just to remind ourselves what the a
b's and c's are c is the side that's
opposite the angle theta so if i were to
draw an arbitrary triangle right over
here
and if this is our angle theta
then this determines that c is that side
and then a and b could be either of
these two sides so a could be that one
and b could be that one or the other way
around as you can see a and b
essentially have the same role in this
formula right over here this could be
b
or this could be a
so what we want to do is somehow relate
this angle we want we want to figure out
what theta is in our little hill example
right over here so this is going to be
theta what is c going to be
well c
is going to be this 20 meter side and
then we could set either one of these to
be a or b we could say that this a is 50
meters
and b
is 60 meters and now we can just apply
the law of cosines so law of cosines
tells us
that 20
squared
is equal to a squared so that's 50
squared plus b squared
plus
60
squared
minus 2
minus 2
times a b
so minus 2 times 50
times 60
times
60 times the cosine of theta
times the cosine of theta this works out
well for us because they've given us
everything there's only really only one
unknown there's theta here so let's see
if we can solve for theta
so 20 squared that is
450 squared
50 squared is
is
2500
60 squared
is 3600
and then
50 times 6 well see 2 times 50 is 100
times 60 this is all equal to 6000 so
let's see if we simplify this a little
bit we're going to get
400
is equal to
2500 plus 3600 let's see that be 6100
is equal to 6000 let me just in a new
color so when i add
when i add these two i get six thousand
one hundred i do that right yeah so it's
two thousand plus three thousand is five
thousand five hundred plus six hundred
eleven hundred so i get sixty one
hundred
minus six thousand
minus
six thousand
times the cosine of theta
times the cosine
of theta and let's see now we can
subtract 6100 from both sides so i'm
just going to subtract 6100 from both
sides
so that i get closer to isolating the
theta so let's do that so this is going
to be
this is going to be
negative fifty seven hundred is that
right five thousand seven hundred plus
yes that is right right because if this
was the other way around if this was six
six thousand one hundred minus four
hundred it would be
positive five thousand seven 5700 all
right and then these two of course
cancel out and this is going to be equal
to negative 6 000
times the cosine of theta
times the cosine of theta now we can
divide both sides by negative six
thousand
by negative
six thousand
negative six thousand and we get and i'm
just going to swap the sides we get
cosine
of theta is equal to
let's see we could divide the numerator
and the dot denominator by essentially
negative
100 so these are both going to become
positive so cosine of theta is equal to
57
is equal to 57
over 60. and actually that's can be
simplified even more
3 goes into 57 is that 19 times yep so
this is actually this could be
simplified this is equal to 19
19 over 20. and we actually didn't have
to do that simplification step because
we're about to use our calculators but
that makes the math a little bit it
makes it a little bit more tractable
right 3 goes into 57 yeah 19 times and
so now we can take the inverse cosine of
both sides so we could get the theta is
equal to the inverse cosine or the arc
cosine
of 19 over 20
of
19
over
19 over 20. so let's get our calculator
out and see if we get something that
makes sense
so we want to do the inverse cosine
of 19
over
20 19 over 20
19 over 20 and we deserve a drum roll
we get 18.19
degrees and i already verified that my
calculator is in degree mode so it gets
18.19
degrees so if we want it around this is
approximately
approximately equal to
18.2 degrees if we want to round to the
nearest tenth so that's essentially
gives us a sense of how steep this slope
actually is